[Applaudissements]
merci bonjour à tout bon jour à tous
l'autre jour je lisais un article de
management qui titrait l'éthique c'est
comme la confiture pratiquement entendu
la plus longtemps j'ai trompé sa
délicieuse mans pro quand c'est plutôt
vrai mais c'est vrai comment interpellé
en tant que que cherche une fille qui
est qu'ils essayent aussi les praticiens
l'équipe du coup je me suis posé la
question de savoir quand légitimement en
droit dans le milieu et le saunier
paraît être une drh aussi de ces
entreprises ont des comportements
vertueux moi je trouve ça fait deux ans
et de l'unité du purin
j'ai bien dit si elle est fortement
perçu parce que bien souvent les points
de vue les objectifs de rentabilité
maximisation du profit qui sont des
titres issus de deux récifs positive
entreprise qui vaut mieux un démêlé fait
que politiques éthiques
albright parfois quand l'original il
vaut mieux une politique ainsi qu il
vaut mieux vraiment un bon discours
dénué d'effets de fondement et
un beau discours un beau site ici du
coup on voit fleurir un peu partout
comme on peut le constater des discours
clasico en cours
si on se lie chez défaut de ne jamais
définir les termes qui les composent on
aura deux technologies humaines
technologies sociales et est ce que ça
signifie concrètement il faut se pense
qu'on arrivera rien avec ce genre de la
proche c'est un peu près clair et la
question se pose c'est quelle attitude
aussi la beauté est ce qu'ils gardent
une bonne façon de parler daisy et de 10
en pratique et la belgique
moi je pense clairement que oui j'en
suis convaincu tout à l'heure je faisais
allusion à l'idée d'une lui contraint à
socialiser
alors qui c'est et aux contraintes
limitent voudrait ça fait un petit peu
peur parfois aux mentalités du herald et
des lieux techno techno économique
pourtant j'aimerais montrer que c'est
pas parfait mais le d'une contrainte
crimes tels que une vraie réflexion
éthique une vraie politique en matière
m cette contrainte c'est cet effet
aucune technologie
khattak ces objets techniques 1,40 et
valeurs et les diffusent autrement dit
la première que youri désastre consiste
à faire payer les tickets technique les
points que ta trace on va se servir et
un lieu totalement fausses
l'absence de neutralité on l'appelle
parfois dans le genre droit canonique la
la non neutralité axiologique les
techniques la philologie c'est un dôme
en étude elle analyse les valeurs
cette absence de neutralité à que
signifier au moins trois choses la
première c'est que nos interactions la
capacité plutôt matérialise rendre
effectifs les choix politiques venaient
dans le vaste représenter les abords une
frappe sur l'habitation où les
algorithmes
j'espère que qu'on passe aux états-unis
en affaire de style donc les artefacts
le rendre effectives les choix
politiques mais ils peuvent aussi
imposer les systèmes socio politique
d'organisation
alors je pense que l'exemple le plus
frappant c'est celui de la centrale
nucléaire qu'il devra là dedans attendre
au dj de la technologie en question
impose un système d'organisation qui est
vertical et autorise m le deuxième
deuxième point sur cette traque et c'est
une erreur tétras et à travers elle a
entendu une trentaine d'heures ainsi à
adopter des comportements
ils réussissent à avoir certaines
nations voilà c'est ça de plus en plus
communément loges et le brayon gâteries
très friands du jeu serait un écran
parmi tant d'autres et c'est sûrement le
petit module qui à la fin de cet épisode
entre les deux affaires
sauf que l'objectif de 6 nuls c'est de
nous inciter devront joindre à rester le
plus longtemps possible
et troisièmement un nom neutre à l'it et
des techniques presque déserte et rex
embarque la façon totalement un disciple
plupart du temps les hazard compact
combat les représentations du monde et
plus particulièrement des retraites
l'humain qui font tout sauf neutre
encore un exemple frappant est celui des
machines à tisser un industriel qui fut
quand on était à hauteur d'enfant et à
diffuser nier que l'enfant était un
nouveau les travailleurs alors que de
nos jours est entendu là représentent
pas la représentation de l'enfant pardo
que celle du tonneau la faune en choeur
ya plus de machines industrielles en
europe au moins le travail pour contrer
séance alors dans le milieu académique à
problèmes cette idée de la non
neutralité elle est absolument
elle est très répandue est parfaitement
accepté le problème c'est qu'elle la
peine encore à se diffuser dans le monde
sphère économique quelques du coup elle
peine à supplanter la catégorie des
visages elle pose moins de problème
majeur
outre canal on retrouve à la rue d'abord
elle déresponsabilise très grossièrement
les concepteurs et fait peser l'ensemble
bonne lâche arnaud morale sur les
utilisateurs qu'ils s'agissent lundi du
de l'harmonisation des pins et ensuite
peut aisément elle ampute la théorie de
grève refusant la régression au public
toute sa partie amont de tout ce qui
vient précisément avant les usages et
qui a le pouvoir n'a rallié le sacro
saint dogme et du je fais parce que je
veux c'est que d'abord la muscadelle
je fais tout une entreprise qui se
resserre guitar hero sera la caponata
jeunesse pour le lead et le monstre
alité des techniques et alice très les
intégrer aux esprits et on évoque
régulièrement et je voulais vous donner
un exemple de réflexion que ça peut
faire naître chez thématiquement ce oui
l'euro c'est un c'est une identité en un
théâtre qui offre deux niveaux
d'interaction le premier c'est le niveau
verbal le second il est appelé à l'image
dans l'interaction de laval
c'est très simple on a connu de plus en
plus notamment grâce aux mots aux
assistants mm dans l'interaction morale
parquet de paris au groupe bolloré pour
une opération annuelle et christine
bulliard elle désigne la capacité que le
robot gr.ii adopter des comportements
asociaux place le plus important pour
eux c'est ce qu'on appelle l'effet de
rien le robot est capable d'estimer un
regard furieux on appelle ça un
dissimulation de l'intentionnalité c'est
à dire le râble d'avoir un point de vue
un carnet entendu et de pouvoir rendre
le monde et c'est chose courante j'ai
donc le rebond peut situer les uns
regardent ce qui est très intéressant
pour l'utilisateur s'il a l'impression
d'être
elle est remplie pour ôter dans la prise
en compte des interactions c'est
extrêmement intéressant mais
l'interaction massa n'est pas que ça
intéresse c'est aussi la possibilité de
gros bras de simuler les comportements
des élections et des comportements
associés comme la joie la tristesse à la
peur la curiosité timidité et sévèrement
c'est intéressant animal on sait
pertinemment qu'elle a des frissons très
large offre indépendante de l'erc
fenêtre qui va être fédéraux on sait que
l'interaction à la tendance à favoriser
un fort claquement en l'air au robot
c'est que la grâce à un tribunal
simul très fortement les cra cultive en
particulier on sait qu'elle prône une
certaine vision de la machine que du
coup elle avait le pouvoir de modifier
le rapport dans l'entretien avec m il ya
des militaires selon l'armée américaine
les militaires qui ont été été risqué
leur vie pour sauver leurs robots
démineurs s'est complètement
contre-productif et alors ces exemples
étrangers est commune a entendu mais il
est très parlant motivé à ces extrêmes
et montre qu'on est capable de faire
pour une machine
indépendamment des visages sauver votre
sait pas lire
alors qu'il faut retenir avec ça c'est
que les si les techniques elle commence
véritablement elle est authentique à
partir du moment où on reconnaît le
pouvoir propre direct six longueurs de
même notre exemple internationale la
question principale à la primaube à se
poser c'est connaissant le pouvoir
propre réflexion au service de quoi
aurait l'air
il est une personne parce que ça glisse
mais elle a le mérite d'abord à lever
responsable du tout et les concepteurs
est en fuite
elle ouvre la possibilité d'une
orientation chercheuse du pouvoir de la
chine un exemple de cette réflexion que
ça fait naître chez phone une idée qui
était de corée c'est celle de la norme
instrumentalisation des émotions arabi
et de ce rassemblement
en gros tu as simple c'est que le
potentiel émotionnel de la chine
vous avez mis au service d'autres choses
que du réenchantement de l'environnement
pour le rendre plus amicales en froid du
chaleureux et docks ou moins
intéressants mais le serbe
manipulatrice quelconque au passage on
n'empêche aucunement le grand beau avoir
des qualités que leurs stats je crois
que tous les services différenciés
digitaux qu'il pourrait être clair sur
l'entité sur la chine chez toi il te
lâchera ses fans une escouade vendre
quelque chose qui compte c'est la façon
dont le franc alors oui la neutralité
c'est une contrainte et on vendra parce
que c'est un principe de réalité
on doit faire c'est une contrainte parce
que ça empêche les concepteurs le nier
la responsabilité provost qui repose sur
une relation mais aussi l'énorme
opportunité
c'est l'opportunité de créer des
nouveaux business models c'est
l'opportunité de breschel dan hardy
confié que la théorie des visages
opportunité de ne pas tout a brûlé à la
gran risa
enfin c'est l'opportunité le garder la
main soit les valeurs qu'on souhaite
diffuser sur le monde vous souhaite
offrir à travers une technologie alors
voilà les tic pour mettre à stella
plusieurs lots est-ce qu'il faut plutôt
la pratiquer comme comme une culture une
culture aux cycles exigeant dans sa
demande du temps sa demande de
l'attention sa demande de la minutie des
grands même parfois pour une altérité se
confronter à la guinée notre regard
nouveau
c'est comment gérer sa commune très
élégamment ce qui nous attend à la toute
dernière phrase de son oeuvre le titre a
dû justement s'appelle petit levier beau
et difficile autant car à 0
[Applaudissements]